am i looking pretty am i looking good
hello everybody good mother sucking
morning
another day another vlog i know these
vlogs are a lot different from what
you're usually expecting but these are
actual
vlogs these are like life vlogs somewhat
sort of i haven't figured out what to do
with all this [ __ ]
i'm not really used to daily vlogging or
going out there and holding a camera
i'll be honest with you is because i i
still feel really [ __ ] weird when i
do it alright baby boy today
is your first day vlog talk first day
vlogging
don't worry about what everybody else so
you gonna go out that door
and you don't give make some content big
exactly are you gonna do when you vlog
huh
you have nothing going on your breast
thinks your titties are huge
your dick is small nobody likes you and
matter of fact i'm not even your friend
and i'm your conscious [ __ ] is that
what you think are you talking to me oh
i actually agree with him
you're a [ __ ] loser i can't do this
i'll get back into the flow of it i
haven't really talked to camera like
this for a living in a very long time so
you know what
there it is
so the other day i had the pleasure to
go out
and follow a sushi chef now not just any
sushi chef this sushi chef is actually
an old friend of mirials and on top of
being an amazing
sushi chef say that one more time you
fat son of a she's a female sushi chef
now
i know for a lot of people out there
you're like oh why do you have to say
female sushi chef why can't i just be
sushi chef
because num nuts i'm not sure if any of
you out there have noticed
that when it comes to sushi chefs you
usually see that it's male
but even more so when it comes to the
art of making sushi
it tends to be very male driven so for
me i thought it would be such a great
idea if i get to highlight
debbie so as you guys all know when it
comes to sushi there's really two
main ingredients aside from all the
other accoutrements fish
and rice so lucky enough i actually got
to follow her to see where she picks up
her fish
okay this is our first stop we're at lux
seafood
um this is like only a mile from my
house it's in downtown l.a
i specifically come here because they're
really good for all the small businesses
they always give you the best quality
stuff even though
other purveyors prefer bigger vendors so
for lux seafood to be really
accommodating to me
and always providing the best from the
best areas
is very important so this is a salmon i
usually use it's like the highest
quality salmon you can get right now
and look at this beautiful uh blue fence
you can see it going from red to pink
so this is like more fattier part it's
called backside toro it's really really
good
that one is albacore oregon albacore
they're currently in season
right now so they they come up all the
way from oregon all the way down to like
the beginning of california they'll
stretch all the way up and down they'll
even be up in washington sometimes
this is our local black cod or sable
fish what they they call them but
they have a flat bottom if you look at
the bottom they're flat they kind of
hang out at the bottom
this is debbie's favorite right here so
these guys
they're pretty popular uh a lot if
you're into fish you should probably
know about them
they're very reputable company these
guys
from new zealand they're pretty much
they set the standard on the farm salmon
oh and the santa barbara uni santa
barbara uni of course
when it's in season right now it's very
very bold very creamy
when it's low tide they tend to eat all
the junk at the bottom of the ocean and
they get a
bitter taste a briny taste when they're
it's a high tide they're floating around
they eat the sweet kelp so
that's when they have that sweet creamy
flavor so that's what the flavor depends
on
so after the fish prepare we went to go
pick up some more ingredients and the
cool thing is i actually got to see her
make her dishes from the ground up and
it really was an
honor to see somebody work on their
craft in their art as as
as seriously and as fun as she was doing
making sushi too
is such a process i'm not sure if any of
you guys actually have tried to
fillet a fish the way japanese sushi
chefs do it
it's [ __ ] insane when i filet a fish
about 80
of the fish the meat's gone i don't know
where the [ __ ] it went but the omakase
sushi dinner that she made for us which
by the way i
wasn't expecting i just wanted to try a
few pieces that she was gonna make
was the best sushi omakase experience
i've ever had in my
life for the first course we have
this wagyu a5 wagyu
carpaccio if you guys haven't had uh a5
wagyu before or any type of like wagyu
beef really really really really fatty
so
thinly sliced and kind of in like that
have you guys had
the chinese style tilapia where they
take hot oil and they kind of sear it
with that
so that's kind of how she finished that
dish off with her sauce and then with
these micro greens on top so we're gonna
go ahead and give this a go
that's freaking amazing
that's good you like it that's good
no if it's bad i usually say it's bad
yeah that's really good
especially with the sauce is a little
acidic and like i said
wagyu is really really fatty and that
hot oil definitely changes like the
profile of that beef is
super good it is it's like butter it's
like beef butter are you just filming
yourself
huh so next up is the
miso salmon with candied sunflower seeds
and on top we have
micro greens as well specifically micro
kale and then we have an edible flower
this is the miso salmon that was cured
in
different types of miso so we have here
the aura king remember we saw it at the
fish market earlier
so this is one of the best salmon from
new zealand
so i marinade in equal parts of
white miso zaikyo miso soy
and mirin so as you can see you can
already tell it's been cured
it's it's firmer because it takes away
the
salt content i mean moisture from the
salt content in here
so the taste is actually really amazing
it's one of my favorite dishes
here we go how much time
oh wow that sunflower seeds makes a
difference
oh the candy sunflower seeds super nutty
very sweet that texture is really nice
specifically with the fish and the
salmon is already kind of sweet too so
it goes really well oh okay
she's dripping she's scared she's
watching right now she wanted to see if
i hate it
it's new it's so good oh this is amazing
okay
debbie ain't playing she ain't playing
am i gonna be in the film get out of
here dude
next up is the amberjack
she suggested um i guess normally she'll
put like uzukosho in it but she likes
the quality of the fish so
we're not gonna add it to it i'm gonna
have it without the soy sauce
to me when it comes to sushi it's i
don't say it's all about the rice
obviously fish quality has a lot to do
with it as well but
um if the rice is generally bad and the
fish is good i won't be able to tell how
great
the fish is because i hate the rice i
can't get past it so
that is a good piece of nigiri next up
we have the
back side of the belly of a yellow piece
of yellowtail
this is a very very popular piece of
like sashimi or biggity that everybody
enjoys
but
[Music]
no wonder i love yellowtail so here we
have
next up the leanest part of the tuna
that
delicious ruby red tuna that everybody
enjoys very much
very clean firm delicious piece of fish
if you get really fresh fish too by the
way
i think a lot of people are turned off
by fish because when people have fish
usually
they're thinking of something that
smells very smelly like very stinky
right
a lot of fish that's prepared for sushi
they do a very interesting technique
where they actually drain the blood out
of it i forgot what the technique is
called but
basically what they do with the with the
piece of fish they actually in
sanguinated so they
they remove all the blood by cutting it
at the gills and at the end of the tail
and what they'll do is they'll stick
this the steel rod in between the spine
and so what they do with that is they
paralyze the fish and the reason why is
because
a lot of lactic acid goes into the meat
of the fish that causes it to spoil a
lot faster so
that's how you get like really clean
fresh fish specifically for like
raw preparations like this yes
that's what it is damn it we have if we
can get this bad boy in focus
we have hokkaido scallop with a zest of
lime
balinese salt which apparently comes
from like you said the trunk of a
coconut tree
hand harvested insane and it's lightly
charred on top with the torch
here we go
hokkaido salad is so sweet it's super
sweet
and of course the pizza resistance we
have
the tuna belly or the turtle with a
nice dollop of sturgeon caviar this
right here though
i already know
this is the money one hi sir actually it
melts
pure men shut up you're so
hyper right throw her out the window
that's so good and once again we're just
gonna go back and talk about the rice
here
great too it falls apart right when you
eat it but it still holds together
when you bring it to your mouth that's
exactly what you want
something that son of a [ __ ] i'm going
to kill this dog
but before we end this video if you're
wondering what debbie
makes to go that you could pick up from
her in los angeles
guess what i've got sit right here for
you baby
look at this this is a chirashi bowl
that debbie makes and this is what i'm
talking about when it comes to
the influences and the experiences that
she brings into her food
and when i open this [ __ ] up you guys
you don't even [ __ ] know
i feel like i'm undressing a girl from
the past you know what i'm saying
anyone say yo look at how beautiful
this chidashi bowl is i mean let me just
read off some of the ingredients
bluefin akami bluefin toro or king
salmon or king miso salmon with torch
skin shioko
japanese yellowtail mexican uni seared
hokkaido scallops japanese a5 wagyu
candied baby anchovies
and smoked trout ro with of course
caviar right there
this right here is the most insane
chidashi bowl i've ever seen and on top
of that
look how beautiful it is so the first
thing that i'm going to do is take this
truffled ponzu this little pipette and
it has a
cute little heart to the left okay and
i'm going to
drizzle it over and let's bite into this
piece of a5
wagyu
it's it's so fatty it's so delicious it
just
okay i don't even know where to start
this thing has a piece of toro and uni
on it right now
yo what the [ __ ] that uni by the way so
creamy
it just oh
i just had a piece of the scallop it has
um
like a yuzu yuzu salt or yuzu on it the
music
show oh so good and like i mentioned
before
we can stick with traditional stuff but
food is meant to be played with and
experimented with and this is
if you want to talk about fish in a
chirashi bowl and sometimes you feel
like you're dipped out
the ratio to the high quality fish in
this
with i mean
i mean for me like i know like fish is
important right
but her sushi rice is so good
just the right amount of vinegar the
right amount of sugar just
well guys i hope you enjoyed this quick
little food adventure
like i said i don't know what i'm doing
with these vlogs but
if i could promote somebody's business
who puts this much love and care into it
i'm gonna do it i know i'm not a great
person i know i'm a piece of [ __ ] i have
a bad temper there's so many
bad things about me but i'll tell you
this before i leave this space
i'm gonna do as much good as i can with
it and if i can promote people who
put this much love and care to their
food i'm gonna [ __ ] do it man
it's amazing i'll see y'all next time
peace